joe biden's speech on wednesday was
nothing more than a stream of reckless
spending
more taxes more taxes higher taxes
more debt more amnesty and more
questions about how
we how you will pay for all of this now
it was unimpressive it was impractical
totally divorced from reality
and even some democrats are asking tough
questions like
west virginia senator joe manchin he
says he's uncomfortable with the cost of
this massive agenda
according to former new jersey
republican governor chris christie
biden's address sounded like a 15 year
old if you gave
them a credit card with no limit and get
this according to a new report from
axios tonight
friends close to christie believe he's
going to run for president in 2024
here to respond to all of this former
new jersey governor chris christie
okay are you thinking about running for
president ask that one we'll get that
one out of the way first
hey listen i certainly are not ruling it
out sean a long way to go yet
but i'm not going to rule it out i think
i have a lot to say on a lot to do for
the country in the future so we'll see
how the
see how the next few years go would you
challenge donald trump in a primary
i wouldn't i would not make my decision
based on anyone else who's running sean
if i believe i'm the right person and if
my family supports it
those are the two things that would be
most important to me okay
you have been at times critical of
donald trump
on the other hand the agenda is pretty
clear he believes
in liberty freedom right low taxes uh
less bureaucracy he wants
constitutionalists on the bench
law and order signature trump right
safety and security in our cities
he fights for school choice secure
borders energy independence
free and fair trade peace through
strength protecting pre-existing
conditions but free market solutions for
health care
do you disagree with any of that agenda
no i all understand entire agenda
and something that i've fought for my
entire political career
but i don't think any of these decisions
ever about running for president
should be made based upon what other
people are doing i think they have to be
based on what you believe in your mind
and your heart
is best for the country and so it's so
long away sean we have no way of
predicting what this is going to look
like
believe me if we were sitting here in
2013
no one was predicting that donald trump
was going to run for president in 2016.
so
let's wait to see what happens overall
how do you grade trump as president
oh listen overall i give the president
an a um
you know but the fact of the matter is
that there were some things that
happened specifically at the end of the
presidency
that i think had some things that
clouded his accomplishments
and that's why we as a as a party need
to emphasize the issues you just talked
about
and be talking about those because i
think those are still incredibly popular
with the american people
and i think that election was much more
about personality than it was about
our issues and the proof of that sean is
that you got 15
members republican members of the house
that are new you flipped a a
governorship
you flip two legislative chambers
republicans had a great night up and
down the ticket
um and you know we've got to remember
that it's because of the issues
that we stand for and what we're willing
to fight for like fighting against
the craziness that is in this joe biden
bill for instance
like a new provision that would pay
someone 75 percent of their salary
in unemployment insurance if they quit
their job
and this is insane you don't have to get
fired or laid off but you get
unemployment
if you quit for what they call good
cause well in this administration
good cause might be if someone's
feelings were hurt um the american
people are not gonna stand for that kind
of craziness
and that's why i'm speaking out and
saying that the president president
biden
is not telling the truth about these
plans and he needs to be called out as a
liar
the liberal media was more than happy to
call use that word
on president trump over and over again
but for some reason we can't use it on
joe biden well i'm not going to hesitate
using it
because a lie is a lie he's lied a lot
and i agreed with your comments on all
of those things
let me ask you about for example
i think every state should have voter id
signature verification
i think we have to have monitored chain
of custody by both parties i think
partisan observers
must be able to watch the vote count
that's actually in the statutory
language of most states
and and certainly i think cleaning up
voter rolls should be
done every year before every election a
lot of that didn't happen
do you believe as i do that that should
be mandatory in every state all of those
things or anything you'd add or subtract
well listen i i there's nothing that you
just talked about that i disagree with
in fact
when i was governor of new jersey we
cleaned up the voter rolls
in a way that had never been done before
in our state and you know our state has
such a history
of voter fraud that one of my democratic
predecessors brendan byrne said
that he made his wife promise that he'd
be buried in jersey city new jersey so
they could stay active in politics
um so you know we're doing those kind we
did those kind of things when i was
governor but
more importantly on the id issue we've
seen recent polls that show that nearly
80 percent of all americans support that
and i don't understand sean
if i go into an office building in new
york city
i have to show my id but i don't have to
show my id if i vote
um that makes no sense to me at all let
me let me ask you so joe biden is saying
even ma vaccinated people
need to be wearing mass you know for
god's sakes
his words right um now my understanding
was if you got the vaccine
that life would return to normal and
life at normal was not what we saw at
the
at the joint session of congress speech
this week and it's not
every every if he's on a zoom call he's
the only world leader wearing a mask and
i just find that part odd do you believe
the vaccinations as we have been told
that once vaccinated it protects you
with a high rate of efficacy
from contracting the coronavirus and
should
it wasn't that where's the promise to
return to normal life is my question
and not only that sean it not the
science not only shows that it protects
you from getting the virus
and getting sick yourself it protects
you from transmitting the virus to
someone else
so look we should have been back in
school in september
all across this country in september of
2020
we still only have 43 percent of the
kids back in school
we should be allowing people who have
taken both doses of their vaccine
to be able to go back to doing what they
do businesses should all be open
ballparks should all be open arenas
should all be open
this is something that when people are
vaccinated they should be able to
participate
as if this not had not happened and so
i don't understand why the delay in that
i don't understand
why the president continues to urge it
when his own cdc is saying something
completely different
politics sean yeah let me talk about
last question
yeah all right six trillion dollars in
in spending we know the numbers don't
add up biden says he can do it not
not add to the deficit okay you don't
need to be an mit graduate to figure it
out
but then it's court packing then it's
d.c puerto rico statehood then it's
ending the legislative filibuster
then it's open borders amnesty ignoring
the laws that are currently in place
like sanctuary cities and states why do
i believe that
if if i ever aided an abetted law
breaking
like is now institutionalized in states
and the situation at our southern border
why do i think i probably get arrested
and put in jail for the rest of my life
well because you're right you would be
and here's the here's the fact here
um all of those things should focus
republicans like a laser
on 2022. elections have consequences
and us losing those two seats in the
georgia senate races
have made all of this possible sean all
of it possible
we need to be loud and proud about what
we stand up for
i said the president was lying about the
georgia voting law because he was lying
and is lying about the georgia voting
law
i said he's not telling the truth about
an infrastructure package that only
spends about 24
of the total on what we know as
infrastructure i said he was lying about
the 1.9 trillion coveted relief bill
that spent only 10 percent
on health care i mean we can't allow
ourselves to sit back
and wait for something to happen we have
to alert the american people to the fact
that these things are happening right
now because that's what's going to stop
court packing that's what's going to
stop ending the legislative filibuster
because we're calling him out as someone
who doesn't tell the truth
last last question rudy giuliani was the
person that first introduced me to you
i don't know if you remember as i do but
he was the one that introduced you
to okay now we know that there were
referrals in inspector general
horowitz's report
right why is it we still don't have a
durham report we had premeditated fraud
on a fisa court
with the phony dossier russian
disinformation dossier hillary paid for
you watch what happened with rudy he had
offered this apparently to the
prosecutors
i really believe at this point in
american history i'm concerned we don't
have equal justice and
application of our laws do you see what
i see
i'm very concerned i'm very concerned
sean about the fact that
there would be a search warrant uh
executed on the home and office of a
lawyer
without regard to the attorney attorney
client privilege when i was u.s attorney
we were very very reluctant to do things
like that
and so i'm concerned about that but let
me tell you something sean as you know
i was a victim of the obama biden
justice department
when they came after me and the supreme
court had to reverse the 9-0
we've got to be vigilant about this and
i'm you know i am a supporter of rudy's
and you know that i've been that for 15
years
all right governor thank you for being
with us appreciate it hey sean hannity
here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else